yeah for those that don't know if you
have Amazon Prime
you can sub for free
easy way to support the channel
all right let's mix it up against the
French I'm gonna play a line I haven't
played in a while
it'll be a similar line to what I played
against the Karo Khan earlier a few
games ago
two nights attack
but this is a bit different because this
is um
a Rubenstein French
and as far as I know
yeah there's this move
Bishop E3 or Bishop D3 first there's
also take and then Bishop D3
but it's the same
line basically
just a transposition
when I was younger I was actually taught
a cool opening trap in this position
Queenie 2 takes takes Knight here and
then Bishop B7 Queen B5
but I think the like
the more practical approaches to take
first and then put the bishop here
oh wow
okay usually the Knight takes
I think the bishop still belongs here
and I think I'll go for each four here
and not holding back
because there's plans later
I don't say there's plans of Queen side
castling and then eventually attacking
but here I think I can just take right
away
this is the idea of H4 is to take
take Knight G5
King goes back and then Queen H5
King goes up is
um like instant mate
yeah I think this is
a pretty classic example of Greek gifts
and it's made possible due to the h-pond
because uh issues for blacks still
remain
and yeah it only gets worse from here
for black
oh there's almost some on poisson
Checkmate ideas but not quite
okay Queen H5
wait let's calculate Queen H5 King F5
G4
King E4
okay that was good enough for me
we have G62
wait where's the force mate though
G6 King here it's made in one king here
that's also made in one
like a g
I mean the the position was almost right
for like castling with mates or
on poisson checkmates
maybe we'll have F3 checkmates
Doe
on this Rosen drove here
let me just show on analysis board
always play F3 checkmates
except when the opponent resigns a move
before it happens
okay that was a fun one hope people
enjoyed that one
a small tidbit though um when I was like
eight or nine years old
I had a chess coach
and we kept a notebook of my opening
repertoire and one of the openings that
I learned from very early on was this
line against the French
I was taught to play Queen E2 with a
very devious idea of taking
or of after takes takes Knight F6
Bishop takes B7
I've been 21 Master games that have
featured this position
and white wins a clean Pond after it
takes Queen B5
so a nice little line and this position
I believe happened at least the same
idea happened in the Ludwig chess boxing
events between one of the the matchups
and I was watching live and I was uh
like filled with Nostalgia when I saw
the position happen on the board